[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
wenn sich die Vertreter von Arbeitgebern
mit denen der Bundesregierung treffen
dann ist das selten ein Fest der Liebe
die Unternehmer wollen immer weniger
Bürokratie weniger Steuern weniger
Abgaben heute aber war die Stimmung auf
dem arbeitgebertag in Berlin schlecht
wie nie die Wirtschaft fürchtet sich vor
einer Rezession und findet so ziemlich
alles falsch was die ampelregierung
gerade macht beim Entlastungspaket zu
kurz gekommen die Energiepolitik
verfehlt das geplante Bürgergeld passe
nicht in die Zeit Bundeskanzler Scholz
sah das naturgemäß anders Frank Buchwald
berichtet
sie stellen Folien her Metallpulver und
Pigmente entscheidende Komponenten für
die Energiewende dafür aber braucht die
Schlenk AG in Mittelfranken sehr viel
Strom in Deutschland gehen die Preise
durch die Decke die Konkurrenz in China
hat solche Probleme nicht es ist
absehbar dass wir in strategischen
Produkten die wir für die Energiewende
brauchen aber für alle Bereiche unseres
Lebens gerade elektronische Produkte
deutlich abhängiger werden von Ländern
die mit Sicherheit nicht demokratisch
regiert werden so wie schlank geht es
vielen das Thema Energie dominiert auch
den arbeitgebertag warum Berlin in
dieser Situation Atomkraftwerke vom Netz
nimmt versteht hier kaum einer auch der
Arbeitgeberpräsident nicht
das fühlt sich so an wie wenn auf der
Titanic alle Rettungsboote über Bord
geworfen werden die Musikkapelle spielt
im Speisesaal weiter und man verlässt
sich darauf dass vielleicht doch nicht
so viel Wasser eindringt und das
vielleicht doch noch ein anderes Schiff
zur Rettung vorbeikommt meine Damen und
Herren das ist aus meiner Sicht aus
unserer Sicht keine verantwortliche
Politik der Kanzler aber kontert bereits
im nächsten Jahr könne Deutschland von
russischem Gas unabhängig sein den
Unternehmen vor allem dem Mittelstand
stellt Scholz Hilfe in Aussicht unter
dulga wir werden dafür sorgen tragen
dass es möglich ist dass die
süddeutschen Atomkraftwerke im Januar
Februar und März noch laufen können
damit es in keinen Fall zu einem Engpass
im deutschen Stromnetz kommt während der
Kanzler drinnen noch redet protestieren
draußen junge Familienunternehmer sie
bangen um ihre Firmen und ihr Appell an
Robert rabek klingt dringend
Atomkraftwerke Einschalten
Kohlekraftwerke aus der Reserve holen
wir kämpfen in der deutschen Wirtschaft
mit den Familienunternehmen um unsere
Arbeitsplätze und wir haben schon die
ersten Insolvenzen erlebt für den Grünen
Wirtschaftsminister ist Atom deshalb nur
ein Problem unter vielen die
Inflationsrate bei fast 8% dem kommenden
Jahr droht eine tiefe Rezession Habeck
wirbt deshalb um Verständnis besonders
bei den Mittelständlern Millionen
Arbeitsplätze stehen auf dem Spiel es
geht darum dass die Unternehmen bestehen
bleiben dass sie nicht pleite gehen dass
sie nicht aufgeben
und dann in der nächsten Phase des
Aufschwunges wieder da zu sein die
atomnote des Ministers für die
Opposition gefundenes Fressen ich gebe
zu das ist ein Teil des Gründungsmythos
der Grünen aber dieses Land kann nicht
allein vom Gründungsmythos der Grünen
abhängig bleiben wenn es um die
Energieversorgung geht Politik in Berlin
Unternehmer Schlenk in Franken wäre
schon ganz froh wenn er endlich planen
könnte für mich ist es wichtig dass ein
wettbewerbsfähiger Industriestrom
wiederhergestellt wird dann können wir
auch wieder Steuern erwirtschaften und
dann lassen sich auch Hilfspakete
finanzieren und das dürfte sich wohl
auch der Finanzminister wünschen
alle fordern dass die Politik jetzt mehr
Unternehmen muss das wollen wir
besprechen mit einer der sogenannten
Wirtschaftsweisen mit Veronika Grimm
nämlich Professorin für
Volkswirtschaftslehre an der Uni
Erlangen Nürnberg und Mitglied des
Sachverständigenrates der die
Bundesregierung bereit guten Abend Frau
Grimm
guten Abend wir haben es gerade gehört
die Industrie wünscht sich bezahlbare
Energie was kann die Politik denn aus
ihrer Sicht tun um die Preise für die
Industrie und die Bürger zu senken
ja aktuell belasten die hohen
Energiepreise die Wirtschaft und auch
die Bürger und das wird auch noch eine
Weile so bleiben die Politik muss da
handeln muss diejenigen entlasten die
diese Belastungen nicht tragen können
aber muss vor allen Dingen auch auf der
Angebotsseite agieren also das
Energieangebot ausweiten und das
bedeutet alle verfügbaren
Kraftwerkskapazitäten aktuell wieder zu
mobilisieren das gilt für die
Kohlekraftwerke die aus der Reserve
holen zu holen sind und das gilt eben
auch für die Kernkraftwerke die
möglichst weiterlaufen sollten um eben
durch eine Erhöhung des stromangebots
die Strompreise zu senken und parallel
muss man Entlastungsmaßnahmen natürlich
beschließen allen voran eigentlich für
die Gaskunden die sind erstmal bei dem
aktuellen Entlastungspaket vergessen
worden aber eben auch für alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger weil einfach die
Strompreise jeden und jede belasten
bleiben wir noch mal kurz auf der
Angebotsseite Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
sagt ja dass der Einfluss des
weiterlaufens der Atomkraftwerke auf den
Strompreis schwierig sein ist falsch
ja ich sehe da verschiedene Vorteile die
Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen
zum einen wird es einen Effekt auf den
Preis geben weil man einfach die
sogenannte mared order nach außen
schiebt das heißt nicht immer setzen
dann die hochpreisigen Gaskraftwerke den
Preis sondern eben auch mal günstigere
Kraftwerke aus der Mitte auf der anderen
Seite werden wir dann wenn wir die
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen lassen auch
über den streckbetrieb hinaus werden wir
weniger kohleverstrom das heißt weniger
CO2-Emissionen und niedrige
emissionspreise die ja sonst auch noch
mal massiv mit der Kohleverstromung
ansteigen würden und im europäischen
Ausland beugt man uns auch also ich
glaube unsere Verhandlungsposition wenn
es darum geht die Institutionen auch für
den Klimaschutz aufrechtzuerhalten wird
sich verschlechtern wenn wir hier aus
der Atomkraft aussteigen in so einer
herausfordernden Situation
wir müssen aber ja trotzdem davon
ausgehen dass die Energiepreise erstmal
hoch bleiben wie also soll aus ihrer
Sicht eine Entlastung aussehen so dass
es Unternehmen und Bürgern wirklich
hilft bis jetzt ist das ja nicht der
Fall
ja genau es sind verschiedene Maßnahmen
angekündigt aber einiges ist auch noch
sehr inkonkret man muss
schmerzhafterweise eigentlich die Preise
schneller an die Verbraucher weitergeben
das führt dazu dass einerseits die
Verbraucher die hohen Preise spüren und
dann auch Gas und Strom sparen das ist
wichtig weil wir sind ja auch in einer
Energiekrise in der das Angebot knapp
ist also gerade beim Gas müssen wir
alles dafür tun eine gasmangellage im
Winter zu vermeiden
gleichzeitig wenn man die hohen Preise
weitergibt muss man aber auch
glaubwürdig entlasten vor allem die
Gaskunden deren Tarife massiv ansteigen
werden aber auch jeden und jede
möglichst zielgerichtet Zahlungen an die
Haushalte im unteren und mittleren
Einkommensbereich bei den Unternehmen
ist es so dass wir viele von den
Liquiditätsproblemen wenn jetzt denn die
Preise weitergegeben würden und der
Kunde auch die hohen Preise schon zahlt
das dann viele von den
Liquiditätsprobleme natürlich nicht
auftreten würden aber da wo dann
Probleme muss man unter Umständen auch
helfen das heißt ihr Votum geht dahin
dass man nicht wie ist die Regierung
jetzt macht alle mit dem
Gießkannenprinzip entlastet sondern ganz
gezielt die kleinen und mittleren
Einkommen
ja ich denke man muss da durchaus bis in
die gesellschaftliche Mitte gehen wenn
sich die Zahlungen für das Gas
vervier-fachen bei einem Haushalt dann
kann das auch ein Haushalt der ganz
ordentlich verdient nicht bezahlen also
man müsste in die gesellschaftliche
Mitte gehen war möglichst wenig mit der
Gießkanne weil man muss ja auch sagen
wir werden einen Wohlstandsverlust
hinnehmen müssen und diejenigen die
diese harten tragen können müssen ihren
Teil tragen wir werden nicht jede und
jeden entlasten können in dieser Krise
das ist auch eine Wahrheit die man
eigentlich aussprechen muss ein weiteres
Thema das mit den hohen Preisen
zusammenhängt ist die hohe Inflation die
EZB versucht ja mit Zinsanhebungen
gegenzusteuern ist dafür aber auch in
der Kritik was wäre für Sie der richtige
Weg aus der Inflation
ja der richtige Weg ist durchaus dass
wir jetzt eine Straffung der Geldpolitik
Erleben der Zinsschritt der jetzt
gemacht wurde 0,75 Prozent das ist schon
der richtige Weg und es wird auch
weitere Zinsschritte geben ganz wichtig
ist dass die Inflationserwartungen in
der langen Frist niedrig bleiben nicht
ansteigen weil wenn die
Inflationserwartungen ansteigen dann
kann das zur Folge haben dass auch die
Löhne ansteigen das vorsorglich
eingekauft wird und dann noch mal die
Preise anziehen also da ist es schon
angezeigt dass die Geldpolitik jetzt
gestrafft wird das wird auch zu einer
Verminderung das Wachstums oder in eine
Rezession führen aber das ist eine
Nebenwirkung die man in Kauf nehmen muss
um eine Verselbstständigung der
Inflation auch zu verhindern
Einsichten von Veronika Grimm die dem
Sachverständigenrat für die
gesamtwirtschaftliche Entwicklung
angehört herzlichen Dank Frau Grimm nach
Nürnberg ich danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
Sendung aufgezeichnet Bundeskanzler
Scholz telefonierte heute zum ersten Mal
seit längerer Zeit wieder mit Wladimir
Putin und forderte einen Rückzug der
russischen Truppen aus der Ukraine ob
der Konflikt der sich gleichzeitig im
Süden Russlands im Kaukasus abspielt
Thema des Gesprächs war ist nicht
überliefert die beiden Ex
sowjet-republiken Armenien und
Aserbaidschan sind seit Jahrzehnten
verfeindet die Nachbarn könnten
unterschiedlicher nicht sein die
Aserbaidschaner reich an Öl muslimischen
Glaubens mit engen Bindungen an die
Türkei Armenien dagegen ein Armenhaus
christlichen Glaubens mit Russland
verbündet
interessieren muss uns das weil nun
wieder schwere Kämpfe zwischen Armenien
und Aserbaidschan ausgebrochen sind
möglicherweise hat Aserbaidschan
angesichts der Schwäche Russlands in der
Ukraine eine Chance auf Gebietsgewinne
gewittert Annegret Oster berichtet
es sind schwere Gefechte zwischen den
beiden verfeindeten Ex Sowjet Republiken
Armenien und Aserbaidschan die diese
Bilder zeigen sollen ein alter Konflikt
der jetzt neu eskaliert beide Länder
beschuldigen sich gegenseitig
durch aserbaidschanische Angriffe sind
nach Angaben unseres
Verteidigungsministeriums mindestens 49
Menschen an der armenischen Grenze
getötet worden
in der Nacht haben Saboteure des
armenischen Militärs verschiedene
Gebiete und versorgungsstraßen vermiet
die aserbaidschanische Armee musste
angreifen um diese Aktionen zu stoppen
der Hass zwischen beiden Ländern ist alt
und sitzt tief in erster Linie um
Bergkarabach wird seit Jahrzehnten
gestritten und gekämpft völkerrechtlich
gehört die Region zur Aserbaidschan von
dem es sich aber 1991 losgesagt hatte
im Herbst 2020 in Flammen die Kämpfe um
die Bergregion erneut tausende Menschen
sterben beide Seiten werfen sich
Völkermord vor damals vermittelte
Russland als Schutzmacht Armeniens eine
Waffenruhe als Teil der Vereinbarung
schickte Moskau anschließend tausende
Soldaten in die Region um den Frieden zu
überwachen baute sich so durch die
Hintertür eine militärische Präsenz im
Kaukasus auf und auch dieses Mal bemüht
sich Moskau auf Bitten Armeniens eine
Waffenruhe zu vermitteln
der Präsident versucht alles zur
Deeskalation der Spannungen an der
armenisch aserbaidschanischen Grenze
beizutragen diese Bemühungen halten an
doch auch die Türkei traditionell eng an
Aserbaidschan gebunden meldet sich zu
Wort
wir stehen an der Seite unseres
geliebten Aserbaidschans wir sagen es
noch einmal Aserbaidschan ist nicht
allein der kaukasuskonflikt im Schatten
des Ukraine Kriegs er könnte zumindest
zu einem Nebenkriegsschauplatz werden
der Konflikt zwischen Armenien und
Aserbaidschan kommt für Russland zum
falschen Zeitpunkt das steht fest fragen
wir nach bei unserer Frauen Moskau für
Becker für guten Abend was sind denn
Russlands Interessen in diesem Streit
zwischen Armenien und Aserbaidschan
ja grundsätzlich ist es ja so dass
Wladimir Putin seinen Einfluss in den
ex-serviert Republiken gerne aufrecht
erhalten oder sogar ausbauen möchte und
blickt man auf die Nachbarschaft von
Armenien dann wackelt dieses Ziel da ist
zum Beispiel Georgien das gerne
EU-Mitglied wäre und seine eigenen
Grenzkonflikte mit Russland hat und da
ist eben Aserbaidschan dass sich eng an
die Türkei gebunden hat Armenien aber
das steht bisher treu an Russlands Seite
das hatte man wieder sehen können letzte
Woche beim Wirtschaftsforum in
Wladiwostok da sagte Nicole paschinian
Armeniens Ministerpräsident man wolle
weiter mit Russland zusammenarbeiten und
man habe keine Angst vor
sekundärsanktionen das ist ein
Versprechen dass jetzt im Angesicht der
westlichen Sanktionen gerade Gold wert
ist und dann spielt in diesem Konflikt
aber eben auch die komplizierte
Beziehung zwischen Ankara und Moskau
eine Rolle die Türkei und Russland die
Arbeiten in verschiedenen Ebenen gut
miteinander zum Beispiel auf dem
Energiesektor aber bei geopolitischen
Angelegenheiten da stehen sie oft auf
gegensätzlichen Seiten das ist in Syrien
so und das ist eben auch jetzt bei dem
Konflikt um Bergkarabach so und in
keinem Fall möchte Moskau das Ankara die
Oberhand gewinnt kannst du schon
abschätzen welche Auswirkungen dieser
Konflikt im Kaukasus auf den Krieg in
der Ukraine haben könnte
also Russland ist da denke ich in einer
Zwickmühle denn auf der einen Seite ist
es so dass sollte Wladimir Putin sich
eines Tages tatsächlich gezwungen sehen
die Truppen in Armenien zu verstärken
dann fehlen diese Kräfte natürlich in
der Ukraine das würde eine Schwächung
bedeuten aber andererseits sollte
Aserbaidschan mit der Türkei im Rücken
jetzt militärische Erfolge gegen
moskauss Schützling Armenien erzielen
können dann wäre das eine Blamage für
das russische Militär so oder so steht
also jetzt durch diese drohen der
Eskalation im kaukursuskonflikt
Russlands Ruf als militärische Großmacht
noch weiter auf dem Spiel sowohl als
Gegner als eben auch als Schutz macht
danke für diese Informationen live aus
Moskau
unterdessen geht der Krieg in der
Ukraine mit unverminderter Härte weiter
die russische Armee hat nach eigenen
Angaben die ukrainischen Streitkräfte an
allen Frontlinien massiv bombardiert der
ukrainische Präsident spricht von
inzwischen 6000 Quadratkilometern die
die Ukraine zurückerobert hätten Dorf
für Dorf rücken nun Polizisten Ermittler
und Soldaten in die ehemals von Russland
gehaltenen Gebiete vor unsere Reporterin
Katrin Eigendorf ist mitgefahren
im Garten eines Hauses haben die
russischen Soldaten alles stehen und
liegen lassen selbst das Auto blieb
zurück in verbifka können die meisten
immer noch nicht fassen dass es vorbei
ist dass ihr Dorf befreit ist
danke allen die der Ukraine geholfen
haben allen auch euch ihr seid unsere
großen Helfer
es war sehr schwer ich habe sechs Monate
mein Haus und meinen Garten nicht
verlassen
die Regierung hat Lebensmittel gebracht
um die Menschen jetzt mit dem
Notwendigsten zu versorgen viele haben
alles verloren
meine Freunde haben mich angerufen und
fragten nach unserem Haus und ich sagte
ich habe kein Zuhause mehr
wir haben nichts mehr wo wir leben
können
es ist das erste Mal dass die
ukrainische Armee Journalisten erlaubt
in eine der gerade befreiten Städte zu
reisen in Ball erkläre haben
Ermittlungsteams die Arbeit aufgenommen
am Rande der Stadt Bergen sie einen
Toten der dort begraben wurde ob er von
russischen Soldaten erschossen wurde
soll nun aufgeklärt werden genauso wie
das was ich in der Polizeistation
ereignete wonach Aussagen von Einwohnern
Menschen im Keller gefoltert wurden auch
hier deutet alles darauf hin dass die
russischen Soldaten sehr schnell die
Flucht ergriffen haben
bei allem grauen die ukrainischen
Soldaten und Polizisten feiern die
Befreiung von balaklia als Wendepunkt in
diesem Krieg
für uns bedeutet das Glauben an den Sieg
ist zeigt dass unser Volk nicht
gebrochen werden kann dass wir auf den
Sieg zugehen und alle besetzten Gebiete
befreien
ob hier im Osten von hakif der Krieg
wirklich seine Wände nimmt das wird sich
in den kommenden Wochen zeigen
bei der Linkspartei rumortes damit
beginnen die Nachrichten von Gundula
gausa gleich zwei prominente Mitglieder
sind ausgetreten so der
Hauptgeschäftsführer des Paritätischen
Gesamtverbandes Ulrich Schneider
ausschlaggebend für ihn die Russland
freundliche Haltung der Linken
Politikerin Sarah Wagenknecht und auch
der frühere Europa und
Bundestagsabgeordnete Fabio demasi hat
die Linkspartei verlassen er wirft der
Parteispitze führungsversagen vor und
forderte die Linkspartei außerdem zu
mehr Engagement für soziale
Gerechtigkeit auf
der Masken Verweigerer der im
vergangenen September einen Tankstellen
Mitarbeiter in Idar-Oberstein erschossen
hatte ist zu lebenslanger
Freiheitsstrafe verurteilt worden als
Hauptmotiv des 50-Jährigen sah das
Landgericht Bad Kreuznach dessen
rechtsradikale Einstellung und
Feindschaft gegen Regierung und Staat
der Mord an dem 20-Jährigen in der
rheinland-pfälzischen Kleinstadt hatte
bundesweit Entsetzen ausgelöst
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
rechnet mit einem zügigen Start von
corona-impfungen mit dem neuzugelassenen
Impfstoff der an die Virusvarianten ba4
und ba5 angepasst ist die EU-Kommission
hat für diesen Impfstoff von biontech
Pfeife jetzt grünes Licht gegeben
Deutschland soll bis zum 3 Oktober
vorerst 19 Millionen Dosen erhalten
die Weltorganisation für Meteorologie
hat den neuen UN-Bericht zum Klimawandel
vorgelegt Fazit die Welt marschiere in
Klimafragen in die falsche Richtung die
Staaten müssten ein Vielfaches mehr tun
um den Anstieg der globalen Erwärmung zu
begrenzen
UN-Generalsekretär gutärisch verwies
etwa auf die so wörtlich kolossalen
Fluten in Pakistan als Beleg für immer
häufigere Wetterextreme der Monsunregen
ist in diesem Jahr besonders heftig den
etwa 33 Millionen Betroffenen droht eine
Hungersnot
es ist eine Art Crashkurs im König
werden den Charles der dritte gerade
absolviert während der Sarg mit der
Queen heute in London ankam und über
Nacht in Buckingham Palace verbleibt
reiste der neue König durchs Land und
besuchte heute wohl eine der
schwierigsten Baustellen der Monarchie
Nordirland bei der offiziellen
Proklamation von Charles dem dritten am
Sonntag war die größte Partei im
nordirischen Landtag Shin Vayne noch
ferngeblieben die Zeremonie sei ja wohl
nur für jene gedacht die der Krone
Gefolgschaft leisten Andreas Weise über
den Antrittsbesuch des Königs in Belfast
freundlicher Empfang für Charles den
dritten an der königlichen Residenz
Hillsboro Castle vor den Toren von
Belfast doch diese Szenen können nicht
über die tiefen Gräben und blutigen
Konflikte hinwegtäuschen die dieser Teil
des Vereinigten Königreichs erlebt hat
und dass die britische Regierung in
London hier viele verärgert mit ihrer
Kontroversen Haltung in der Frage von
brexit und offener Grenze zwischen
Nordirland und der Republik im Süden der
König versucht zu beruhigen
und mit Gottes Hilfe nehme ich meine
neuen Pflichten an und für das
Wohlergehen aller Einwohner Nordirlands
zu sorgen
nach seiner Ansprache Treffen mit den
Spitzen der nordirischen Parteien und
auch wenn Michelle und Nil von der Iris
republikanischen Shin Fan den König
sichtbar herzliche Beileid ausspricht
und den Vierteln Belfasts die sie
unterstützen mit der König als
Repräsentant eines Besatzungsregimes
gesehen
das hat mit der Geschichte hinter der
Monarchie zu tun deswegen begrüße ich
ihn nicht
es gibt zu viel Hass hier jeden Tag geht
es darum ob man protestantisch oder
katholisch ist ich wäre beinahe mal
erschossen worden
und der Historiker Brian fini erklärt
uns dass viele mit dem neuen
Staatsoberhaupt ein Problem haben
hat eine Menge Arbeit vor sich vor allem
beim irischen nationalistischen Teil der
Leute hier er war und ist
kommandierender eines
fallschirmjägerregiments dessen Soldaten
1972/14 Menschen in Derry und davor 11
in West Bell fast getötet haben beim
sogenannten bel murphy-massaker der
andere Teil der Nordiren war heute mehr
als glücklich den neuen König zu
begrüßen als er am Nachmittag vor der
saint-ands-kathedrale ankommt hier sind
vor allem Unionisten versammelt sie
wollen um jeden Preis Teil des
Vereinigten Königreichs bleiben
und das ist nicht einfach für ihn hier
zu starten da sollte den Weg der Queen
weitergehen um die verschiedenen Gruppen
hier zusammenzuhalten
am Trauergottesdienst für Queen
Elizabeth nehmen auch Irlands
Präsidentin Ministerpräsident sowie die
neue britische Premierministerin teil
dann noch mal Händeschütteln winken was
man eben als König so macht und kurz
danach ist Charles der dritte wieder
unterwegs Richtung London
und hier gibt es jetzt noch mal
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und mit
Gundula täglich melden
Finanzmarktexperten sich
verschlechternde Konjunkturdaten gestern
das Münchner Ifo-Institut heute das
Mannheimer Zentrum für europäische
Wirtschaftsforschung ZEW alle eint die
Sorge um die Energieversorgung Valerie
hallern der Börse und das ZEW sieht
weitere Herausforderungen genau wobei
die hohen Energiepreise schon als
größtes Problem wahrgenommen werden
inzwischen erwarten praktisch alle
führenden Wirtschaftsinstitute eine
Rezession in den kommenden Monaten die
vom ZEW befragten Profi Anleger sind
sogar so pessimistisch wie zur Zeit der
Finanzkrise 2008 Kommentar eines
Ökonomen schlechter geht es eigentlich
nicht mehr ganz oben steht die Sorge vor
energieengpässen im Winter und einem
Konjunktureinbruch umso wichtigen
Absatzmarkt China aktuelle Zahlen zeigen
schon jetzt einen Rückgang bei Aufträgen
Produktion und
Antworten miese Stimmung nun auch wieder
an der Börse nach einigen Tagen
kräftiger Erholung war der DAX heute
wieder unter Druck mit mehr als
eineinhalb Prozent im Minus Hintergrund
sind Nachrichten aus den USA demnach
hält sich dort die Inflation
hartnäckiger als man erwartet hatte sie
lag im August immer noch bei 8,3 Prozent
bedeutet dass die amerikanische
Notenbank Ende September die Zinsen
weiter deutlich anheben könnte und das
ist in der Regel eben nicht gut für
Aktien zumal damit das Risiko größer
wird dass die Fett die amerikanische
Konjunktur abwürgen und somit eine
Rezession dort auslösen könnte die
gleiche Sorge wie in der EU danke
valerina Frankfurt
so bislang stark umstritten die
Arbeitszeiterfassung das
Bundesarbeitsgericht hat nun entschieden
in Deutschland müssen Arbeitszeiten
künftig systematisch und komplett
erfasst werden und nicht wie bislang nur
in Bezug auf Überstunden und
Sonntagsarbeit diese Umsetzung einer
europäischen Rechtsprechung dürfte sich
auch auf
Vertrauensarbeitszeit mobile Arbeit und
Homeoffice auswirken
im Südwesten Frankreichs sind erneut
Waldbrände ausgebrochen nach wie vor
begünstigt durch anhaltende Hitze bei
Sumo etwa 30 Kilometer westlich von
Bordeaux sind bereits über 1000 Hektar
Land abgebrannt hunderte Einwohner
mussten ihre Häuser verlassen starke
Winde und über 39 Grad heiße Luft aus
Marokko erschweren die Löscharbeiten
jede Geschichte muss einen Anfang eine
Mitte und ein Ende haben aber nicht
unbedingt in dieser Reihenfolge das
sagte Jean-Luc Gouda Revoluzzer
Regisseur des französischen Films und
radikalster Vertreter der Nouvelle Waag
der neuen Welle in der Kinokunst
Wackelkamera Originalschauplätze bisher
nie gesehene Sprünge beim Schnitt godar
gilt als Erfinder des modernen Films auf
die Frage ob das Kino tot sei wenn er
selbst sterbe antwortete er das hoffe
ich doch dann hätte ich wenigstens ein
Ziel in meinem Leben dort der Färber und
Claudio Armbruster erinnern an die
kinol-legende die heute mit 91 Jahren
gestorben ist
ich habe heute keine Lust zu solche
Spiele radikale Geschichten
radikale Blickwinkel radikale Schnitte
ich liebe ein Mädchen das einen
wunderschönen Nacken hat alles anders
alles frei ohne Regeln wunderschöne
Hände alles keine Regel gibt muss man
sich auch keinen technischen Regeln
unterwerfen
sich selbst einen Weg finden Bilder wie
das Leben zu machen
freies Denken freies erzählen zum ersten
Mal Handkamera und kein künstliches
Licht nouvelle das ist godar einzige
Regel ein Film hat cool zu sein Jean sea
Berg
fährst du mit mir nach oben und Jean
Paul Belmondo cooler geht's ja kaum gut
da war Kino revolutionär ein radikal
linker Provokateur der im Mai 1968 den
Abbruch der Filmfestspiele von Cannes
Solidarität
[Musik]
auch fürs Fernsehen arbeitet er aber nur
kurz es ist nicht seins seine Liebe ist
das Kino
wenn die Leute in den Saal kommen heben
Sie den Kopf beim Fernsehen senken sie
ihn deshalb brauchen wir das Kino denn
wir müssen den Kopf oben tragen
gudas Videokunst damals rauschhaft
rätselhaft
radikal intellektuell
und radikal unverständlich
was heißt schon verstehen das ist nicht
schlimm man versteht nicht unbedingt
immer alles sofort vor dem verstehen
muss man erst einmal etwas in sich
aufnehmen
was für Bilder was für ein Film
Hauptrollen die Architektur des Hauses
und die der Bardot
eine Frau wird zum Köder und aus Liebe
wird Hass
ich habe dich so sehr geliebt
aber jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr
und ich verachte dich weil du diese
Liebe nicht mehr in mir erwecken kannst
die Verachtung eines von so vielen
Meisterwerken das meisterregisseurs
Jean-Luc guter
[Musik]
das war es von uns ich hoffe wir waren
heute radikal verständlich hinweisen
wollen wir Sie gerne noch auf die
zdf-reportage 37 Grad gleich im
Anschluss diesmal geht es um
extremsparer sehr sparsame Menschen für
die jeder Cent zählt aus verschiedenen
Gründen
und gegen 0:30 Uhr meldet sich
Christopher Wehrmann mit unserem
heute-journal Update und dann allen
Sportergebnissen von diesem Abend einen
schönen Abend und tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter im Südwesten
Deutschlands gab es heute 30 Grad so
warm ist die Luft die von Süden her zu
uns kommt ja und ziemlich feuchte und
diese Luftmasse stößt auf die Luft aus
dem Norden die ist kühler die
Luftmassengrenze die sich hier ausbildet
ist ziemlich stationär so regnet es über
längere Zeit in der Nacht also Regen im
südlichen Nordrhein-Westfalen in der
Mitte bis nach Osten und auch nach
Südwesten dort dann auch Gewitter und
dann kann es kräftig schütten im Norden
merkt man kaum etwas davon Temperaturen
gehen dabei auf 9 Grad in der
norddeutschen Tiefe Ebene zurück 20 Grad
im Südwesten Deutschlands noch einmal
eine tropische Nacht
ja und morgen Vormittag kräftiger Regen
über der Mitte teils mit Gewittern
durchsetzt auch nach Osten hin im Norden
merkt man nichts davon und auch im Süden
ist es noch trocken am Vormittag aber
zum Nachmittag rutschen Regen und
Gewitter weiter in den Süden und dann
schüttet das teilweise kräftig vor allem
der Nähe von Gewittern weiterhin im
Norden größtenteils trocken einzig
Richtung Schleswig-Holstein mal ein paar
Schauer ja und die Regenmengen 20 bis 50
Liter auf den Quadratmeter ja weil
Gewittern kann es durchaus noch mehr
werden dann kommen die Regenmengen oben
drauf oder ins Stau lagen da wo sich die
Wolken an den Bergen Staunen da schüttet
es auch kräftig ja und die Temperaturen
dazu 16 Grad unter dem Regen 25 bis 26
Grad noch mal im Süden richtig warm ja
und dann am Donnerstag rutschen Regen
und Gewitter in den Süden bei 16 bis 22
Grad und auch danach bleibt es
wechselhaft ein schönen Abend